welcome to the show which almost didn't
happen today we were probably 10 minutes
from having to cancel today's show it is
quite a story and I'll tell it on the
bonus show today it's a good one there
are two concepts that I've been talking
about which really are necessary
concepts to understand if we want to
interpret and understand the Trump
presidency and these two concepts are
the Overton Window and creeping
normality and these are two terms that
will help to shed light onto how we are
all truly becoming numb to different
degrees to Donald Trump's lawlessness
and there's a really good letter to the
editor in the LA Times from over the
weekend which said that much like a
victim of abuse who gets hit once and
then twice and then ten times you start
to become numb to that abuse and in the
same way we all to some degree have
become numb to Donald Trump's
lawlessness his ignoring of rules and
regulations his being a scofflaw and
most importantly his suffering no
consequences from it either and the
letter to the editor in the LA Times
very astutely points out many of the
examples of this the abuses of power and
the corruption and the cronyism and the
violations of the Hatch Act but I
understand what it is that's happening
here the outrage and the disarray that
people are experiencing as emotions over
the Trump presidency are logical
emotions but they are emotions that
consume a lot of human energy of
emotional energy and at a certain point
most reasonable people will sort of give
in and move on because it's just
draining and exhausting to continually
experience those emotions and when you
add to this a significantly radical move
of the Overton Window to the right and
the creeping normality that we have
experienced over the last two and a half
years it's a recipe for an authoritarian
president who's very actions have made
the population numb to his blatant
disregard for what's right and moral and
sensible as a reminder the Overton
Window is sort of a range of what's
acceptable for debate in the public
discourse what are the if we talk about
abortion or we talk about taxation what
are the sort of accept
that boundaries on the left and right of
that debate and the right has
significantly benefited from pulling
that Overton Window to the right which
moves the middle to the right as well
and creates more of an uphill battle for
the left to fight against creeping
normality is another term where you
can't just jump to many of the debates
we're having today they have to creep in
as normal debates if Trump on day one
ordered a strike on Iran and then
cancelled it at the last second and we
found out that it was because he was
told that that last second how many
people would die there would be much
more outrage than there was just two
weeks ago when that very thing happened
because this new status quo under Trump
first had to become the baseline status
quo and it's really important to
understand that normalization doesn't
mean people start to think the things
Trump is doing are okay what's Trump
doing is fine is not what creeping
normalization means it means that you
sort of start white flagging it and
throwing your arms up in the air and
saying this is all insane I've got no
power over any of this stuff I'm gonna
go play a video game or watch a Netflix
show which is in a sense a sort of
logically adaptive behavior for the
individual health of individuals
although it's extremely unhealthy for
our society to allow this creeping
normalization of radical ideas to seep
in now I wanted you not to get me wrong
there are many trumpets who do genuinely
think everything that Trump is doing is
okay I'm not talking to them in this
segment okay I'm talking to people with
a good head on their shoulders people
who don't think that what's going on is
okay but are experiencing that fatigue
that I've described before as well which
is why I'm trying to take weekend's
totally off from news and politics as I
did over the long fourth of July break
it's not that Trump as an example it's
not that when when Trump glorifies
dictators and criticizes our allies we
think it's fine
it's that we've become used to it and
what can we really do about it anyway
other than of course vote him out in
2020 which I hope we're all going to do
so this is really dangerous it's going
to take a really long time to prepare
the damage that has been done and the
removal of Trump from office in 2020 is
merely step one of I don't know how many
of many many steps and the goal here is
that we have to understand that we have
to some degree become numb and we have
to fight what is admittedly that natural
reaction if we can because we don't want
that numbness to allow any level of
indifference of inaction when we can
have an effect on the society around us
on the country around us and this also
relates to the very disturbing recent
trend of extreme right-wing ideology
becoming mainstream at least in some
circles and that's exactly what I want
to talk about next one of today's
sponsors is impeach the card slap game
you can't slap Donald Trump in real life
but you can slap them in this hilarious
fast-paced two-player card game and you
can get it for ten percent off when you
go to david pakman.com slash impeach
impeach the card game is awesome for
parties or when you're having a few
drinks i've been playing it with some
friends of mine it combines clever
satire about the trump administration
with really funny high-quality cartoon
artwork all in a very lively card game
that's easy to learn but it stays
interesting every time you play it
because of how well designed it is and
how much thought went into the humor and
the political commentary impeach the
cards slap game is perfect if you're
looking for something fun and casual to
do with your politically minded friends
or family members it'll make a perfect
gift for anyone you know who has a sense
of humor about donald trump don't forget
that Father's Day is coming up and when
you go to david pakman.com slash impeach
not only will you get 10% off the game
you can also get 10% off all of the
other hilarious clothing and accessories
in their online store t-shirts coffee
mugs tote bags featuring funny political
cartoons about trump that you can't find
anywhere else get a super fun witty gift
for yourself or someone you know whether
it's impeach the card slap game or
anything else in the gift shop and get
10% off all of it when you go to david
pakman.com slash impeach